.
Test, Test.
Scheint zu gehen.
Hallo Leute, da bin ich.
Wie versprochen gibt es heute
Riemen.
Und wir machen
Set Server Szenarios.
Allerdings nicht alle
76 oder wie viel es auch immer da gibt.
Aber ich warte erstmal, bis der Stream
richtig angelaufen ist.
Ja, übrigens, die Häkchen, die ihr hier seht,
die sind
von unserem Azubi.
Der hat
also
Aufgabe 1, 2,
3 hat er nicht gepackt.
4, 5, 6 hat er gepackt.
9 hat er probiert, hat nicht
geklappt und 11 hat funktioniert aha na ja gucken wir mal die anderen hat er
wohl noch nicht gemacht so wie es aussieht
ich habe einen pro account bei set servers den habe ich privat abgeschlossen
mal weil sie mir riesenakt ist bis das auf der arbeit irgendwie genehmigt und
macht und tut habe ich für ein jahr mal abgeschlossen und wenn unser azubi nichts
zu tun hat kann er sich hier austoben aber so viel hat er noch nicht gemacht
deswegen viele der szenarien kenne ich auch nicht nur mal kurz zusammengefasst
was das ist bevor wir jetzt komplett random hier anfangen das ist eine seite
die hat 76 glaube ich irgendwie so in dem dreh 76 szenarien ein szenario ist
immer ein kaputter server unser szenario besteht daraus du bekommst ich kann es
ja mal kurz hier zeigen du bekommst eine beschreibung was kaputt ist auf dem
server oder was erledigt besser gesagt was erledigt werden soll auf dem server
nicht wirklich was kaputt ist auf dem server meistens ist was kaputt aber
nicht immer was erledigt werden soll auf dem server und dann machst du das und am
ende gibt es einen check meine lösung knopf ob das richtig gemacht hast du
wenn du richtig gemacht hast dann kriegst dir ein häkchen wird außer da
wo man schon Häkchen hat.
Und die
Szenarien, die
sind geordnet von
Easy bis Medium über
Schwer. Und wir haben alle
Szenarien gemacht vor drei Jahren oder so.
Da gab es nur 30.
Also ein paar kenne ich davon.
Den Großteil
davon habe ich aber vergessen.
Und den Großteil der Aufgaben kenne ich gar nicht.
Habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Also bin ich mal gespannt. Und ich habe mir überlegt,
oder ihr könnt ihr euch überlegen,
Chat, wie wir das am besten machen.
Soll ich von oben nach unten anfangen?
Wir machen mal zum Aufwärmen vielleicht mal
so fünf Easy-Dinger oder so, ja.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen random,
oder? Wir machen random.
Weil ansonsten
machen wir heute alle,
na, heute alle Easy werden wir wahrscheinlich,
sonst würden wir heute nur Easy machen, das nächste Mal
nur Medium und das nächste Mal dann nur schwer
oder sowas. Das ist, glaube ich, auch
nicht, wird da nicht
deine Bestzeit angezeigt. Ja,
das gibt es auch, aber das ist ziemlich sinnlos,
finde ich. Gerade wenn man die Szenarien
schon kennt, da kannst du theoretisch
den Makro vorher machen
und das tippt dann ein, was du
brauchst. Das ist nix.
Ah ja, und was ich nicht vergessen darf,
Chatge,
ich kenne euch ja, ihr könnt mir denn nicht die Finger
davon lassen, ne? Ich muss wieder
meine Adress... Ups,
das jetzt. Moment.
Wo ist mein Terminal
hin? Ach, da ist es ja.
Ich muss wieder meine Adresszeile verstecken.
Weil wenn ich meine Adresszeile nicht verstecke,
dann ist der Chat wieder am Start.
Der Chat macht dann den hier.
Deswegen muss hier oben,
irgendwie hier so, geht der Browser dann auf.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Nope.
Da muss es hin.
Oder? Ne, da muss es hin.
Da geht ja gleich ein Fenster auf.
So muss das da hin.
Sonst sieht man nämlich die URL.
Und wenn man die URL sieht,
dann...
Komm, hier oben haben wir mal C-Matrix an.
Ah, der kann das nicht.
Auf einer Zeile.
Dann muss doch ASCII-Quarium her.
Und...
Ich...
Weil das Problem ist, wenn man die Adresszeile sieht,
könnt ihr die abschreiben und seid dann auch
per Terminal auf dem Server drauf.
Und da hatten wir schon ein paar Mal,
das hat nicht gut funktioniert, wenn der Chat
damit rumfuscht noch.
Also das machen wir heute.
Vorher zeige ich euch mal was anderes, Leute.
Richtig nice.
Ich habe gestern noch OpenCode
ordentlich konfiguriert
für AI-Stells. Guckt mal.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie nice das ist.
Wohlgemerkt alles kostenlos zur Zeit
und mal gucken, wie es in Zukunft aussieht.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist, wenn man kein Geld
ausgeben will, bisher die beste
AI
Programmierumgebung, die ich
gefunden habe. Ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Wir sind in dem Rust-Projekt von gestern drin.
Da starte ich OpenCode.
OpenCode
hat ein nices Terminal-Interface.
Man hat drei verschiedene
Modes. Build, Plan,
Ask. Ask habe ich hinzugefügt
mit einem eigenen Prompt. Oh, fällt mir ein.
Jetzt kann ich ja Prompt-Engineering
auch noch in meinen Lebenslauf schreiben, wenn wir
schon dabei sind. Oder was sagt ihr?
ein prompt geschrieben schon gleich prompt engineering ich meine wir hatten
mal einen bei uns der hat sich beworben als linux admin und er hatte dann so
skills wie fünf jahre linux erfahrung bla bla bla und am ende kam raus hat
einmal ubuntu auf einer vm installiert vor fünf jahren also ziemlich ziemlich
sinnlos so und jetzt kann ich zum beispiel habe ich mir ein custom command
angelegt, nennt sich explain
und dann
nimmt er jetzt das hier, also
das hat Toolzugriff, das
AI
Programm, ich habe ihm allerdings nur
bestimmte Tools erlaubt, er darf nur Dateien
lesen und Bash darf er
nur LS ausführen und
Cat nur, nachdem er mich gefragt
hat, das heißt das Ding kann mir nichts kaputt
machen, so jetzt sage ich slash explain
da kommt hier dieser Standard Prompt, den
habe ich da schon quasi vorgefertigt
jetzt guckt danach in meinem
Ordner, was es da für Dateien
gibt und dann schreibt er mir eine
10-zeilige Zusammenfassung.
Seht ihr, Feind kann er nicht starten, jetzt benutzt er
LS.
Grab darf er auch nicht machen, bla bla bla.
Jetzt erforscht er quasi mein
Projektverzeichnis,
liest meine Rust-Dateien
ein, guckt sich an, um was
das Projekt ist und dann sagt er hier,
this project is a real-time process monitoring web
application written in Rust.
Also im Prinzip genau das, was stimmt.
Und jetzt fragt er mich, möchtest du
denn eine volle übersicht über das projekt mit details architektur diagramm sagen wir mal jetzt
wohlgemerkt das geht in die cloud das ist nicht lokal also wäre damit feines an irgendwelche china
chinesen seine projekte zu verschicken kann das benutzen kostet übrigens nichts wenn man
kostenpflichtige models benutzt bekommt man das hier neben auch angezeigt wie viel man ausgegeben
hat also auch sehr nice gemacht er kann lsps verwenden language server protokoll also spricht
Der kann Rust-LSP verwenden, der kann Bash-LSP verwenden.
Da kann er noch besser die Projekte analysieren.
So, jetzt guckt er, was hier Sache ist.
Jetzt erstellt er mir ein Overview über das Projekt mit Architektur-Diagramm.
Das ist ganz nice, wenn man neu ein Projekt geklont hat.
Und dann mal guckt, oh ja gut, hier verrutscht er ein bisschen.
Da muss er ja so Optimierungspotenzial, sehe ich.
können wir den prompt reinschreiben pass auf dass bei den diagramm alles richtig allein ist
so und jetzt kann man sich hier das ganze so übersicht verschaffen finde ich eigentlich ganz nice
man kann natürlich auch reinschreiben was man will als text aber ich habe diesen explain habe ich ein custom custom command
angelegt weil man das öfters öfters braucht wir können jetzt ja mal was ausprobieren leute ich habe eine idee wir nehmen jetzt mal hier dieses
szenarios
rechnen rechnen dass sie jetzt mal ab
Achso und was der auch ganz nice kann ist, zeige ich euch vielleicht auch nochmal, bevor
wir mit Z-Servers anfangen.
Also wir brechen ihn jetzt mal ab hier an der Stelle.
Was der auch, wo der wirklich ganz gut ist, wenn man hier fast hier, generate, generate,
mit punkt md file ist die usage of the tool and default values and how to config
with and variabel sommer kann sich da ruhig verschreiben da checkt das trotzdem ich kann
im vierter chance fixer licht das sind doch alles anwendungsfehler da gibt es nichts zu fixen guck
Und jetzt haut er dir eine Readme-Datei raus.
Die kannst du dir jetzt nochmal angucken.
Kannst sagen, okay, hier, Realtime, Web-Application, CLI-Usage, Kommando.
Also er hat im Prinzip genau das gemacht, was ich gesagt habe.
CLI-Argumente, Adresse Port.
Er baut Environment-Variablen, hat er nicht reingeschrieben.
Das sollte man vielleicht ihm nochmal sagen, dass er das macht.
Ach nee, hier hat er, hier hat er Environment-Variablen reingeschrieben.
So, beste.
Also die letzten drei Monate auf der Arbeit sind meine Readmes auch alle erstellt worden mit AI.
So, und jetzt, guck mal, jetzt fragt er mich auch, should I save this Readme-File?
Jetzt sage ich yes.
Und jetzt fragt er mich, darf ich das denn?
Weil das habe ich extra so eingestellt, dass mir das Ding nichts kaputt macht.
Der erstellt jetzt eine Readme-Datei, beziehungsweise fragt mich, ob er eine Readme-Datei erstellen darf.
Er hat nur Zugriff auf Cat.
und das muss ich bestätigen also nur der kann nur cat verwenden um dateien zu
schreiben guckt jetzt fragt er mich hier darf ich
das hier ausführen blablabla rast dann drücke ich jetzt einfach enter und jetzt
in der datei erstellt jetzt laber da noch ein bisschen rum was eigentlich
keinen weiteren
Sinn mehr macht.
File has been created. Blablabla.
So, quit.
Jetzt gucken wir mal.
Wim, readme.md.
Ah, ne.
Wow, das hast du da erstellt.
Readme.md.
Guck.
Und da haben wir die readme.
Und die ist in der Tat.
Läuft die KI lokal auf deinem Rechner?
Ich hab die auch,
ich hab die mit
QuenCoder hab ich ausprobiert.
Das ist aber nicht so gut.
aktuell ist das GLM 4.7, das läuft in der Cloud.
Man kann das auch mit lokalen AIs verwenden, aber die sind alle nicht so gut.
Guck, und jetzt habe ich meine Readme hier am Start.
Jetzt probiere mal noch, ich lösche die jetzt übrigens mal wieder.
Richtig cool, wie konntest du das so eingrenzen, zeige ich dir.
Also das ist OpenCode, benutze ich hier.
Wohlgemerkt auf GitHub OpenCode muss man das richtige Repo auswählen.
Das ist das richtige Repo.
OpenCode.AI OpenCode ist das falsche, obwohl das richtige Repo OpenCode.AI in der URL drin stehen hat.
Alles klar, habt ihr verstanden?
Das muss wohl so gewesen sein.
Ursprünglich gab es dieses OpenCode.AI Repo.
Das wurde dann gekauft und der originale Owner hat den Namen behalten und die Firma, die es gekauft hat, hat den Source-Code bekommen.
Und die haben dann irgendwann den Source-Code archiviert, ein neues Produkt daraus gemacht und er hat sein eigenes altes Repo geforgt und weiterentwickelt in besser.
Also super, super Objekt, was da wieder abgelaufen ist.
Ganz ein AI-Stilz.
So, OpenCode, OpenCode hat eine Config-Datei, die sich OpenCode nutzt, ja, wir haben sogar für, also hier die Frage, nutzt ihr Sprachmodelle schon ausgiebig auf der Arbeit, wir haben sogar für sensitive Daten so einen eigenen Fork von ChatGPT, also den kann man sich bei Azure kaufen, bei Microsoft, die garantieren einem dann auch, das verlässt nicht die EU oder nicht Deutschland und bla,
Weil die können viel sagen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Und da kann man das verwenden.
Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, zum Programmieren, ich finde ChatGPT, also zumindest das, was es unter ChatGPT for free gibt aktuell, finde ich ziemlich ein Müll.
Das hat mir schon so viel Blödsinn.
Wir haben es letztens mit Rust ausprobiert.
Schon so viel Blödsinn zusammen generiert.
Also was ganz gut ist von aktuellen Chats, die free sind, die ich bisher gesehen habe, ist tatsächlich diese, ist das hier, das finde ich gar nicht so übel, der KI-Modus von Google, das war auch ganz gut, da ist irgendein Gemini-Model drunter.
drunter perplexity für irgendwelche research sachen ist auch ganz brauchbar
dann gibt es noch 10 chat oder wie das heißt für die china chinesen models aber
wenn man was will was einfach und schnell funktioniert ist tatsächlich
dieser google ein modus gar nicht so übel so oder man verwendet open code
und kann zurzeit glm 4.4.7 kostenlos verwenden auf deine frage hin wie ich
das eingerichtet habe mit den shell commands es gibt eine open code jason da
kann man ein guck hier habe ich open koder nicht auf korder quen koder habe
hier lokal hinzugefügt als model aber benutze ich nicht du kannst das hier so
kannst du das einstellen du kannst pro modus du bekommst das nicht kostenlos
sätgen haben haben wieder so ein programm open source maintainer bekommt
kostenlos da könnte ich ja sagen da mache ich ein alibi kommit beim fiat
champ und bewährt mich für kostenlosen copilot
oder oder ich darf bei dir im repo einen pull request machen mit fix typo und sagt dann hier
kommt mal da habe ich das gemacht aber die entscheiden wer qualifiziert ist okay ja guck
also so kann man das hier einstellen dass das ist hier dieser modus den ich angelegt habe der quasi
read-only ist zum größten teil da kannst ihm sagen okay generell erlaube ich dir als tools keine
außer read dateien webfetch da kann nämlich auch online nachfragen und erlaube ich dir auch und
hier kann man dann die permissions für bash noch mal ein bisschen genauer vergeben und kann sagen
okay du darfst nichts aus für den bash außer ls ist immer erlaubt pwd ist immer erlaubt ansonsten
ist nur kett erlaubt aber nachdem du fragst das kann man übrigens bei cloud code auch machen so
ähnlich aber auch kurz geht so und permissions hier unten habe ich generell eingestellt
permissions web fragt er immer und auf externe externe verzeichnisse darf er gar keinen zugriff
haben und das ist das custom command war stellen erlegt habe also das ist das
ist richtig wir können jetzt ja mal was ausprobieren wir nehmen jetzt war ich
habe eine idee ist ja was wir wissen was wir ausprobieren
wir machen es mal auf und sagen ihm jenner
rate me to do list with all scenarios from hier mal gucken was da rauskommt
webfetch wird er mich gleich fragen ob er darauf zugreifen darf
permission guck hier webfetch permission required to so das ist except ist nur
einmal accept, A ist
always accept.
Für diese Session, glaube ich.
Also
Open Code ist bisher, ich habe ja in den letzten
Wochen da viel rumgewurschtelt und rumgeprobiert,
bisher das,
was mir am besten gefallen hat.
Wenn man nichts bezahlen will.
Guck jetzt,
ach guck mal hier, jetzt macht er mir eine
stimmt das 25 Scenarios
easy? Waren das nicht mehr?
Ne, tatsächlich, 25 Easy-Szenarien.
Okay, jetzt erstellt ihr mir eine To-Do-Liste für unseren Stream heute.
Excellent.
Ja, hab eine Frage. Möchte mein Konto von der PS4 auf den PC übertragen?
Keine Ahnung. Kein Schimmer.
Oh, jetzt hier die weihnachtliche Musik.
Also man sieht, GLM 4.7 ist jetzt nicht unbedingt der schnellste.
Aber was Programmieren angeht, ist die Qualität echt nicht verkehrt.
Und es ist gerade ziemlich beansprucht wird das.
Also man wird auch ein bisschen gedrosselt und muss manchmal 10 Sekunden warten, bis es losgeht.
Okay, would you like me?
To save this to do list as a file. I can format it as markdown. Yes, save as markdown
To do.md
Ich habe keine ahnung wie man das macht
Ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt meine playstation glaube ich also mit mit psn account irgendwie vier jahre oder so nicht mehr angefasst
keine ahnung
Wie man das macht.
Was muss man da überhaupt auf den PC übertragen?
Ich meine, man kann sich doch im Browser mal einen PSN einloggen und dann.
Weil PS4 Games auf dem PC wir es eh nicht haben.
Was meinst du mit auf den PC übertragen überhaupt?
So, jetzt erstellt er mir das To-Do-File als Markdown.
Guck, man wird gerade ein bisschen gedrosselt, weil GLM 4.7 kriegt ziemlich viele Anfragen aktuell.
Spielstern... Ne, das geht.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das geht.
Geht das? Kann man PS4
Spielstern auf den PC
übertragen? Das kann ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen, dass das geht.
Das wäre extrem pock, wenn das geht, aber ich kann es mir
irgendwie nicht vorstellen.
Guck mal hier.
Jetzt ist er...
Jetzt ist er hier am abkacken. Egal.
Lassen wir ihn mal laufen.
Ach ja, jetzt hat er es geschafft.
Jetzt hat er es geschafft.
Unavailable Tool.
Available Tool Bash.
Ja.
Mach.
Five Header AI.
Nutzt du LLMs in der Arbeit?
Ja.
Relativ viel sogar, weil es einen einfach viel effektiver macht.
Also was ich nicht mache ist,
ich brauche ein Tool zum bla bla bla bla bla bla
erstellen mir mal
und dann einmal ausprobieren und sagen geht
und raus damit, das mache ich nicht
ich benutze das beispielsweise wenn ich neue
Programmiersprachen lerne, wenn ich irgendwelche YAML Files
kontrollieren muss, irgendwelche JSON Files
äh, explain für
Kubernetes Kommandos und solche Geschichten
dafür ist das super, das macht dann
viel effektiver
jetzt haben wir, guck hier, modified files
to do md
und was man jetzt machen kann
By the way, Arch Linux.
Was man jetzt machen kann ist,
wenn er fertig ist,
er will jetzt noch gucken, ob er das erstellt hat.
Was man jetzt machen kann ist, man kann ihm diese Datei mitgeben.
Ich mache jetzt mal eine neue Session.
Wir gucken uns die Datei
erstmal an.
So, zisch ab.
Du, du, MD.
Das sieht gut aus.
Das sieht...
Na doch.
eigentlich ganz gut, oder?
Für eine To-Do-Liste.
So.
Was machst du alles mit Kubernetes?
Wie jetzt?
Du meinst, was ich da administrativ mache?
Oder wofür wir das benutzen?
Letztendlich laufen da jede Menge
Java-Anwendungen bei uns auf der Arbeit drauf.
Wir haben keine Datenbanken in Kubernetes.
Das meiste ist Cloud SQL oder tatsächlich
noch Oldschool On-Prem Oracle.
Also zu 90%
was da läuft, sind Java-Anwendungen.
Hypernetis, genau.
Kubernetes.
Das ist die richtig geilen Leute.
So, und jetzt probieren wir
nochmal was aus.
Jetzt fragen wir ihn mal hier.
Look at
to do MD
and pick
a random
scenario for me.
Mal gucken, ob er das
checked.
Okay.
Was wurde gepickt?
Borked Engine X.
Difficulty medium.
Time 15 Minuten.
Type fix. Fixed Engine X
not starting. Okay, Leute. So sieht's aus.
das da sollen wir machen ich zeige euch aber mal einmal exemplarisch wir machen
mal zum zum aufwärmen und exemplarisch machen wir mal irgendwie keine ahnung
die ersten zwei oder drei easy jetzt unser azubi anscheinend schwer getan
war mal die easy aufgaben aber 1234 mal gucken
da steht 30 minuten und was hat die über sagt die ei 15 minuten hat verkackt
fehlt also dass ihr mal seht wie das wie das funktioniert man will ein szenario
aus dann kriegt man allerdings die musik ist mir zu weihnachtlich gerade auch
fertig man wählt ein szenario aus dann drückt man auf run dann erstellt er bei aws im hintergrund
eine linux vm in der zwischenzeit während er die linux vm erstellt habe ich nicht gemacht wenn man
während der linux vm erstellt kann man sich mal durchlesen was man eigentlich machen soll und zwar
das ist die erste easy aufgabe die ist dementsprechend auch sehr easy da steht jetzt
dass eine das ein programm permanent nach war lockt bedlockt schreibt und die festplatte voll
macht so und ich soll gucken welches programm das ist und das killen das ist wirklich easy
und wenn man es wenn man das gemacht hat gibt es dann da unten so einen check knopf und dann sagt
da ein ob man es gepackt hat oder nicht es gibt auch hints wenn man es nicht schafft
die erste aufgabe lasse ich jetzt den chat erledigen weil das ist wirklich easy
ich brauche was zu trinken noch hier ich habe nur ganz kleines bisschen tee noch zu wenig
habe ich ein bisschen was runter geschmissen auf die erde muss man kurz aufheben ups ups
gut und jetzt wisst ihr jetzt seht ihr auch gleich warum ich hier oben ein terminal laufen
habe. Open Server in Terminal.
Zack. Weil hier oben in der
Adressleiste
hier
würde jetzt eine URL
stehen, die ihr abtippen könntet.
Und
dann würde
die auch hier auf der Shell landen.
Okay.
Auf geht's, Chat. LS of Bad Lock.
Ach, Moment.
Wo wird das Lock überhaupt erstellt?
Äh.
War Lock. Ah, War Lock Bad.
war log
lsof
bad log
achso kaum macht man es richtig
hier
pit 578
und jetzt
ich kann das jetzt nochmal zeigen
tail-f bad.log
guck da wird laufen irgendwas reingeschrieben
dreimal pro Sekunde so ungefähr
und mit lsof
kann man gucken, welcher Prozess
File Handles auf hat auf die Datei.
Und es ist dementsprechend
BadLog.py
Jetzt kann man entweder
die Oldschool Variante machen und sagen
Kill 578
Was fällt euch noch ein, was man machen könnte?
Außer Kill mit der Pit.
Pause.
Champ.
P-Kill.
Kill All. Ja, da wollte ich letztens
Auf die zwei Sachen wollte ich letztendlich raus.
Gucken wir mal.
Kill all, bad log.py kann man machen.
Zack.
Und weg ist es.
Reboot könnte man theoretisch auch machen,
aber danach wird es wahrscheinlich wieder automatisch gestartet.
Wir haben übrigens, glaube ich, gar keine Root-Rechte.
Oh, doch, haben wir.
Also könnten wir rebooten.
So, und wenn man fertig ist, gibt es hier unten jetzt einen Knopf.
Check my solution.
Vorher, wenn man es nicht schafft, kann man sich auch die Clues angucken.
Da sagt er hier, guck doch mal mit PSAux, was da läuft.
Nächster Clou ist, aha, guck doch mal hier, F-User.
LS-Off geht auch.
Und dann sagt er Kill.
Also der führt einen quasi, wenn man gar keine Ahnung hat, so ein bisschen an die Lösung auch ran.
Ist ziemlich gut gemacht.
Wir haben es aber gekillt, sagen jetzt Check My Solution.
Ui.
Und sobald man auf Check My Solution geklickt hat, das muss man wissen,
schießt dann den Server ab, um Kosten zu sparen.
Das heißt, wenn man noch was machen will,
nicht auf Check my Solution klicken.
X-Solution, genau.
So, so sieht das aus. Machen wir mal die Aufgabe
Nummer 2, die hat unser Azubi
auch easy gepackt.
Sass
Karton, Cartoon.
Counting IPs.
Run.
Der Solution ist voller
Big Streamer mittlerweile
geworden, habe ich gesehen.
Es ist nice, dass das für ihn geklappt hat. Ich weiß es ja noch,
der hatte mal
ziemlich schwere Zeit, auch
wo es dann auf YouTube nicht so lief, wo er
dachte, er macht das jetzt nicht mehr hauptberuflich
und sowas. Finde ich gut, dass es bei ihm
auf Twitch geklappt hat.
Auch wenn ich so gut wie nie reingucke.
Aber es ist trotzdem nice.
Der ist ja auch in Madeira. Ach,
alle sind sie in Madeira. Was machen die eigentlich
alle in Madeira? Muss man da so wenig Steuern bezahlen?
oder wie?
Sparen.
Tja.
Madeira ist nicht Europa,
ne? Das sagt, sonst könnte ich
Vacation machen.
Also bei mir auf der Arbeit
haben sie jetzt groß angekündigt, sie unterstützen
jetzt die Leute bei, wenn sie Vacation
machen wollen. Ach, das ist Portugal!
Ja, dann kann ich in Madeira theoretisch Vacation
machen aber dann spare ich keine steuer
natürlich in madera aber bloß auf dann läuft ja wahrscheinlich sehr bestimmt
nicht groß erläuft er laufen irgendwelche deutschen influenza über den
weg das muss nicht sein
nach gran canaria das ist spanien da wollte schon lange mal wieder hin
Da kann man dann Workation machen für drei, vier Wochen. Also das haben die jetzt angekündigt bei uns, dass sie tatsächlich das allen Mitarbeitern ermöglichen wollen, remote aus dem EU-Ausland zu arbeiten bis zu, boah, frag mich nicht, x Wochen im Jahr.
Da kannst du dann quasi nach
Cancunaria fliegen
Zuletzt im Urlaub
Boah, das ist schon eine ganze Weile her
Wo ich wirklich größer im Ausland im Urlaub war
Also so in den üblichen Ländern, wo es war
Ich glaube
Der letzte Urlaub, das ist auch schon eine ganze Weile her
Da war ich in der Türkei
So zu Zeiten, wo das noch ging
Das ist tatsächlich schon eine ganze Weile her
Ich hatte die letzten Jahre auch überhaupt keinen Bock
Ich habe mir das erste Mal ein paar Wochen überlegt, dass ich wieder mal Bock hätte, nach Gran Canaria zu fahren.
So, und deswegen, das werde ich wahrscheinlich mal machen.
Da fahre ich nach Gran Canaria, das ist Spanien, und da mache ich Workation.
Mal für drei Wochen.
Das heißt, ich mache bis 15 Uhr Homeoffice.
Oder 14.30 Uhr, mal gucken.
wenn ich früh anfangen geht das bestimmt und dann kann ich da noch an strand und
bisschen rum stelzen das eigentlich nicht ich hatte mal lange haare ich
hatte mal so richtig headbanger frisur ruhig weil war ich da so 15 16 14 15 16
er noch gar noch ein bisschen länger so bis bis bis bis um die 20 hatte ich die
so 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19
20 dann nicht mehr.
Also wirklich lang.
So wie die ganzen Headbanger.
Nee, nee, ich bist zum Arsch.
Ganz so lang nicht.
Du bist ja Heavy Metal Beste.
Gut, auf geht's.
also was sollen wir auf dem server erledigen der web server access log file at home admin
access log ok access log access log ist da das ist access log
der ip ist unique warum wenn ich habe ich gar nicht richtig lesen der fall
consists of one line per http request with the requesters ip address at the beginning of each
line okay ja hier sieht man ja sieht man ja also ip immer am anfang so und jetzt soll herausfinden
welche ip adresse hat die meisten requests in diesem file und dann sollen wir das ergebnis
mit der IP nach heißt
IP.txt schreiben. Okay, Leute.
Jetzt könnt ihr ein bisschen mitraten, wie man das
am besten macht.
Cat.access.log
Als erstes würde ich sagen,
holen wir uns mal
die
die IP raus.
So, jetzt haben wir die IPs.
Creppen.
Creppen ist vielleicht
ein bisschen
kompliziert.
würde bestimmt auch gehen, jetzt da eine Schleife drüber
Cap minus C und Counten
mit WC
das wird wahrscheinlich auch gehen
also ich würde sagen, man kann sowas hier machen
man kann das sortieren
und dann gab es doch sowas, was Sort minus C
oder Unique minus C
genau, Unique minus C gab es
und dann sorten wir das
Ganze nochmal
So, also was das jetzt gemacht hat ist, ich habe die Datei gesplittet an Leerzeichen und habe das erste Feld genommen.
Also quasi vom Anfang der Datei bis zum ersten Leerzeichen.
Dann habe ich das Ganze sortiert, das muss man machen, ohne Sortfunktion nicht.
Dann Unique-C, Unique-C zählt quasi, wie oft die Sachen vorgekommen sind, bevor es nur noch eins draus macht.
schreibt davor und am ende sortiert das noch mal dass die ip mit den höchsten höchsten meisten
einträgen unten steht so und jetzt sagen wir echo sowie die das ja wollen sagt nach highest
ip.txt check my solution bäum kunst so sieht das aus so ich will sagen jetzt haben uns aufgewärmt
oder? Dann gucken wir mal.
Ähm.
Das sollen wir
jetzt machen. Cape Town.
Borked Engine X.
Wieso 1 und nicht 0?
Hä?
Was meinst du?
Machen noch die, die der Azubi nicht geschafft hat.
Okay, was hat der Azubi denn nicht geschafft?
Needle in a Haystack.
Und the command line murders.
Das kenne ich.
Das habe ich mir mit ihm angeguckt.
Ich finde, das ist nicht easy.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was ihr zu sagt, ob das easy ist.
Ich habe es nicht fertig gemacht.
Ich habe mir das aber mit ihm angeguckt, weil er mich gefragt hat.
Das fand ich gar nicht easy.
Ich fand, das ist eher ein Medium gewesen hier.
Ach, du meinst das Cut-Kommando?
Wieso eins und nicht...
weil es bei 1 anfängt zu zählen.
Es gibt kein 0-tes Feld.
Das ist wie Lua.
Das fängt ja auch bei 1, bei Array Indexes an.
So, da bin ich mal gespannt, was ihr zu der Aufgabe sagt.
Ich finde, die war schwerer als Easy.
Hat mich nämlich unser Azubi zugefragt,
weil er nicht weitergekommen ist.
Ich habe ihm noch ein paar Sachen erzählt, aber
ich habe sie nie fertig
gemacht. Also keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß noch so ungefähr, um was es geht.
Da könnt ihr mir
jetzt ja mit Rat und Tat
zur Seite stehen, Chat.
Weil wir wissen ja, Massify IQ.
Jeder Prime Sub
und jeder
nicht Prime Sub natürlich doppelt
IQ
increase für den gesamten Chat.
Und heute können wir echt jeden IQ gebrauchen.
müsst ihr euren inneren hacker man darauf beschwören damit wir das hier gelöst kriegen
hi iq sie ist er geht schon los beste es haben noch bessere chancen es zu schaffen
Danke für den Sub.
Excellent.
Das ist so ein Dosey-Mode.
Auf, erstell den Server.
Wir können ja schon mal lesen, was wir machen sollen.
Also.
Okay, was sollen wir...
Äh, warte mal, was sollen wir machen?
Description. This is the command line
murders with small twists.
Enter the name of the murderer
in the file MySolution.
For example, John Smith.
Okay. Hints are at the base of
home admin CLMysteryDirectory.
Enjoy the investigation.
Boah, das wird eklig. Also, zeigt mal her.
Also, was sollen...
Wo sollen wir hin? In welches Verzeichnis
sollen wir überhaupt?
Nach Admin?
Sind wir wahrscheinlich?
Admin?
CL Mystery.
Okay, und da gibt es jetzt was?
Cheat Sheet Instructions.
Lesen wir mal Instructions.
The Command Line Murderers.
Blablabla.
To figure out, also wer es gewesen ist.
You want to start by collecting all the clues at the crime scene.
Crime scene file.
Das ist sowas wie in der Grundschule, so eine Textaufgabe.
Das habe ich immer gehasst.
Don't use the text editor to view any files.
Leute, ich habe eine Idee.
Wir sollen doch den Namen rausbekommen, oder?
Wir sollen doch den Namen raus...
Wir machen jetzt Trick 17.
Wir sollen doch den Namen rausbekommen.
Wo ist denn...
In welcher Datei stehen denn die Namen?
People.
Welches Layer ist mein Azubi 3.?
Der hat jetzt im Februar seine Abschlussprüfung.
Haben die eigentlich...
Gibt es da auch welche mit 3 Namen?
oder haben die immer nur Vor- und Nachname?
Okay, wir versuchen mal was.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Hat er das Projekt gemacht, ja?
Jetzt alle hashen. Genau, das hatte ich vor.
Genau, das hatte ich vor.
Wir bescheißen jetzt ein bisschen.
Also jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken,
wie wir hier die Namen alle rauskriegen.
Nehmen wir mal e-grab.
Wir sagen vom Anfang der Datei
Non-Creedy bis zu M oder F.
Nicht, dass jetzt wieder Leute getriggert sind, weil es hier nur Männer oder Frauen gibt.
Minus O.
Äh, A.
Ne, siehste?
Siehste, das ist tatsächlich, bin ich zu low IQ für hier einen Regex zu bauen.
Bist du?
Bin ich zu dumm für einen Regax zu bauen?
Was für ein Regax?
Was ist ein guter Regax dafür?
Ich will den Namen bis zum ersten
M oder F.
Also Non-Creedy Regax
ist doch eigentlich gar nicht verkehrt.
Oder so
Creedy Regax? Ne, das
matcht zu viel.
Wie kriegen wir das hier jetzt raus?
Wer hat da...
Okay, wir können es einfach mal dumm machen.
Ja, die ersten zwei Wörter.
Ich weiß doch nicht...
Ob...
Das welche gibt mit drei Namen.
Ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Es könnte doch welche mit drei Namen geben.
Wenn ich einfach nur die ersten zwei Felder ausgeben will,
könnte ich sagen, irgendwie so.
Äh, 1 und 2.
So, äh, was?
Wie macht man das? 1 bis 2.
Ne, hä?
What?
Ach, das ist ein Tap.
Das ist ein Tap.
Okay, dann müssen wir es doch mit AWK machen.
Aber ich weiß ja nicht, ob das funzt.
Weil wenn welche
drei verschiedene, also drei Namen
haben, dann funzt das nicht.
Wie printet man nochmal Leerzeichen?
So?
Wie printet man Leerzeichen?
Egal, print spaces.
How to save your space.
Okay.
Aha.
Ah.
Ich hab's.
Exzellent.
So, jetzt können wir nur hoffen, dass das alles die richtigen Namen sind.
So.
Schauen wir mal.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
So, dann machen wir eine Schleife da drüber.
Kann man...
Ja, das ist gut.
Das war eine Schleife da drüber.
Und dann hashen wir das Ganze.
Da haben wir beschissen.
Da haben wir dann richtig beschissen.
For, i in, Dollar.
Ah, ne, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das müssen wir...
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Das funktioniert nämlich nicht, weil da Leerzeichen drin sind.
Muss man das hier quoten?
Ne, man muss...
Ach, ne, man muss while read machen wahrscheinlich, dass das funktioniert.
Oder muss...
Oder? Ne, wenn man das hier quotet,
das bringt ja
wahrscheinlich nix.
Ich glaube, man muss
while read machen.
Jaja.
Okay, ne, wir müssen hier sagen
while read
i. Oh, wie war das jetzt nochmal?
Do echo i
done? Ne.
Äh.
Warte mal.
Wie ging das nochmal?
While, read?
So?
Nee.
Drei?
Ach nee.
So.
So, ne?
Ohne.
Was war denn da jetzt die richtige Syntax?
Das waren es drei?
Okay.
Bash.
While, read.
Exzellent.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das direkt in Ende 5 Summen pipen kann.
Ja, das suche ich eigentlich.
Genau das.
Wie ging das mit Name Pipe nochmal?
Aber so war es ja nicht.
Weil Read...
Nein, ist egal, wie das heißt.
War das mit Name Pipe...
So?
ich kann mir das nicht merken weil ried name pipe aha einfach okay gut
das ist der magic nein und jetzt aber das hier mal weg minus n das kein juli
hinten dran kommt und jetzt nach md5 so ein Python. Ich gebe zu, das ist ein bisschen
beschissen jetzt. Also das ist ziemlich beschiss von mir. Und jetzt sagen wir hier grep9bba.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob da das Richtige bei rauskommt. Wenn nicht, habe ich es nicht
richtig gemacht da und chat es hat nicht funktioniert
das hat nicht funktioniert okay dass der versuch zu bescheißen hat nicht
funktioniert
Tja.
Dann müssen wir das wohl doch...
Was ich machen wollte ist,
ich wollte alle, guck mal, wir wissen doch,
den MD5 Summe von der Lösung.
Ich wollte jetzt einfach
alle Namen MD5
hashen und dann gucken,
wo die Summe bei rauskommt.
Also ich wollte es von hinten nach vorne
machen, um zu bescheißen, ja.
Aber das hat nicht funktioniert.
Bestimmt, weil es unterschiedlich
lange Namen gibt.
Guck mal, hier gibt es bestimmt
Hier gibt es bestimmt People
die
ja guck mal, die
gibt es bestimmt People, die mehr als
Vor- und Nachname haben.
Aber komm,
wir lösen das
so wie es gedacht ist.
Weil die
Beschissvariante hat nicht
funktioniert.
Aber ich sehe hier nur zwei.
Lass uns doch noch mal eine Sache ausprobieren.
Wenn ich die New Line weg mache.
Ah!
Da haben wir es!
Da muss New Line hinten dran, damit es stimmt.
New Line muss da hinten dran.
Okay, der Name ist...
Achso.
Wartet mal, Chat.
Wie kriege ich jetzt den Namen raus?
Also, wir haben es jetzt gefunden.
Äh.
Ah, ich weiß wie.
Wartet mal.
Wir geben jetzt
2 Lied Echo.
Dann
Echo.
nein
ja auch gut
alter okay und das schreiben wir jetzt in der Datei hier
plupp.txt so und dann kopieren wir uns den hash
das war jetzt ziemlich also es war jetzt beschiss
wie wir das gelöst haben.
Also.
Wim.plop.txt
Joe Germusca.
Der war es, Leute.
Sad Mouse.
Verbackt.
Joe Germusca ist es gewesen.
Wo soll man das hinschreiben?
Nach
WimMySolution.
Zeig mal die Hints.
Mach ich.
in c l mystery ins ins end one try poke okay
das sind die hints try poking around world fire by using the head command okay
first 20 line of people fall also mal kreppen in der crime scene
die adresse also irgendwie adresse raussehen dann irgendwie die das auto oder so mit dem der gefahren
ist.
Wir schauen mal, ob das jetzt stimmt, was ich gemacht
habe. Check my solution.
Bam! Fertig.
Geschafft.
Das haben wir aber jetzt gecheatzt, ne?
Durch die Brust ins Auge
sozusagen.
Okay, und was haben wir hier noch?
Das hat unser Azubi auch nicht geparkt.
Needle in a haystack.
Was sollen wir denn hier machen?
Run.
Also, in Home Admin Data gibt es verschiedene File, alle mit dem gleichen Content.
One of these files has been modified.
Okay, in einem der Dateien ist ein Wort mehr drin.
Ich muss gucken, welches Wort das ist und in das Solution-File putten.
Geiler Satz, oder?
Putte dir auch immer Sachen in das Solution-File.
Warte mal, bis das gestartet ist.
Auf jeden.
Top.
Putten in das Solution-File
Sollte Standard vorgehen werden
Da sind wir dran, Leute
Wir haben das mitgenommen und sind dran
Und wir nutzen auch
Wir nutzen auch schöne Synergie-Effekte
Dabei
Um die low-hanging fruits
Abzugreifen
starten please super agil das ist agil nach safe und nach was es da sonst noch alles für modelle
gibt open terminal server also jetzt noch mal kurz checken also was wollen wir machen
nach data sollen wir gehen in data liegen jetzt dateien ok wmd 5 summen einfach mal alle dateien
und gucken wo die summe unterschiedlich ist hier in file 76 ist die summe unterschiedlich ja weil
76 okay 76 das heißt wir vergleichen jetzt 76 mit
guck mal hier ist ein newliner hinten dran und da nicht aber das zählt ja nicht
er will ja nur wörter haben also wenn ich da jetzt per auge kreppe dann dauert
das ganz schön lang.
Seitdem du in den neuen Laden bist, hast du viel weniger zu ranten
über die Manager. Das stimmt, die sind auch deutlich fähiger.
In Diff wird's nicht tun.
In Diff wird's nicht tun,
weil Diff das zeilenweise macht.
Guck.
Diff macht es zeilenweise.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die Möglichkeit gibt.
Word.
Vergleich der Unterschiede.
Was?
Word?
OS, irgendwie so.
Okay.
WDIF gibt es, habe ich noch nie gehört.
WDIF.
Okay, wir haben Root-Rechte, glaube ich.
Haben wir?
Ja.
ab install wd noch nie benutzt noch nie benutzt hast jetzt viel hast du hast du
per auge gekreppt gerade im stream augen krepp
Kannst du dieses Emote hinzufügen?
Zeig mal, wenn das was taugt.
Ja, kann ich machen.
So.
WDF.
WDF File.
Zum Glück ist das nicht File 6-7.
Und File 9-90.
Äh.
Ich sehe da jetzt keinen Unterschied, Leute.
Ah, hier, guck mal.
Hier wird das hervorgehoben, dass da ein Wort drin ist.
Was kann denn WDF sonst noch so?
Hat das irgendwie Color oder sowas?
Color?
Nee.
WDF halt.
Okay, aber das Wort wird es sein hier
Eureka
Hat das nicht
Hat das nicht der
Archimedes, der in der Badewanne
Geschrien hat
Er hat es
Irgendein Grieche war das
Also jetzt müssen wir nach
Wim
Hier nach solution
Eureka
Check my solution. Bäm geschafft.
Hedemes
Okay
Dann würde ich sagen chat gehen wir mal zu der eigentlichen aufgabe
Die uns die KI randomized hat die wir machen sollen
Das war das hier.
Borked Engine X.
Das lesen wir uns erstmal in Ruhe durch.
Das ist jetzt eine schwierigere Aufgabe.
Das gehört zum Medium.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch eine von denen, die ich noch nicht kenne.
Also.
Der ist der Engine X.
Web-Server install and manage by System D.
Na gut, kommt man heutzutage nicht drum herum.
Curl, bla bla bla.
Returns failed to connect to local host.
Port 80, Connection refused
Fix it, so when you curl
you get the default Nginx page
Kann das, haben wir das schon mal gemacht, Chat?
Ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern
Okay, run
Fail to connect to log
Da lauscht bestimmt noch was auf dem Port, hä?
Da läuft bestimmt noch irgendwas anderes
Da können wir gleich mal mit Netstat gucken
Ob da schon was anderes läuft.
Ne, Netzdead.
Netzdead, Leute. Netzdead.
Engine X hat ein Config-Fail. Das kann auch sein.
Bis wir mal in die Logs gucken.
Netzdead. Ich bin Netzdead-Enjoyer.
SS, das Kommando
wirkt so politisch unkorrekt
deswegen netstat
Moin Lars
netstat ist
deprecated, ja genauso wie ifconfig
und ich verwende trotzdem noch ifconfig
Ja gut, ich hab Neofetch auch zu Fastfetch
Alias, ne, ne umgedreht
Fastfetch zu Neofetch Alias
Was gab's Feines zu futtern?
Gans
Wir haben Gans geholt
Also bei uns gibt's so ein Restaurant
Das bietet an, dass du quasi so ein fertiges
Gericht zum Abholen
Da kriegst du ganze Gans zubereitet mit Klößen und Rotkraut und Bratappel und so.
Das kriegst du dann alles in...
Musst du Töpfe mitbringen.
Und dann kriegst du...
Hat 100, 120 Euro gekostet.
Das war aber auch ein riesen Ding.
Haben wir zwei Tage lang dran gefuttert mit drei Leuten.
Okay, auf geht's.
Dann schauen wir doch mal.
Also, Fehler ist folgendes.
Stellen wir mal den Fehler nach.
Nicht, dass der uns jebaitet und es gar keinen Fehler gibt.
Was macht denn curl-i überhaupt?
Curl-i?
Habe ich keine Ahnung.
Aber das Gleiche passiert auch hier.
So, also auf Port 80 gibt es nichts.
Let's erst einmal root werden.
Let's dat minus tulm gucken.
Auf Port 80 läuft nichts.
Also das ist es schon einmal nicht.
Systemctl status engine x.
ist fehlt aha unexpected semi colon in
der fuck in etc engine x1 enabled default haben wir es doch schon
unexpected semi colon zeigt dass auch eine zeile an wo das unexpected ist
Ah, direkt in der ersten Zeile?
Ach da!
Halb hinter dem...
Ah, guck mal, da ist ein
Semikolon da oben. Seht ihr es?
Erste Zeile hier.
Löschen wir das Semikolon?
Und jetzt sagen wir
Systemctl...
Ups.
Ich wollte einen Wort
löschen in der Shell. Das ist Ctrl-W.
Aber Ctrl-W im Browser ist...
ist tab schließen system ctl restart engine x
datus
datus engine x running kurl bam oh oh leute wir haben es immer noch nicht
gefixt internal server error ist jetzt gesagt ist jetzt angesagt internal server
Es ist noch nicht ganz gefixt.
Aber.
Immerhin.
Der Nginx Server läuft jetzt.
Dann gucken wir doch mal in die Log-Files.
Ob da irgendwas steht.
Nginx Logs.
Error.
Schauen wir doch mal da rein.
Ist T-Mux eigentlich drauf?
Ne.
Less Error.
was was was was was was was
too many open files
ah ist das irgendeine limits geschichte
ist das ne
etcu limit oder irgendwie sowas
limit limit
oh ne wo wo wo ist das
wo lag
das ganze zeug nochmal
etc security limits
ETC Security
MonkaS
Jetzt
Limits
Limits D
Limits Conf
Ist da irgendwas drin?
das kann ein systemd unit kann das auch sein also hier ist schon mal nix hier ist schon mal nix
gesetzt hier ist hier ist nix nix nix nix drin
anderes kann es eigentlich nicht sein so ein limits d war leer ok etc systemd
Wo liegt der Kram?
ETC System D ist eigentlich richtig.
Da gibt es dann sowas wie
U-System.
Nginx.
Nginx HTTP Reversal Network.
limit number files hier guck mal das ist es meist mal raus
restart das ist zum dm reload
restart curl local hopp man hier bekommt mama sowie style
drüben stehen.
Funst!
Wir haben es gefixt.
Kurl!
Das soll man machen und da soll 200 rauskommen.
Ja, wir haben es gefixt.
Check my solution.
Äh, ups.
Falscher Knopf.
Geschafft. Okay, dann next.
Mark it as done
and pick me
a new random
one.
Gibt es schon Netzteile written in Rust?
Hundertprozentig. Es gibt gefühlt mittlerweile alles written in Rust.
Ja, save to TodoMD.
While you decide, there is a new random scenario.
Easy. Quick maths.
Quick maths.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie er die Datei editieren will, wenn er keine Rechte dazu hat, Dateien zu editieren.
Do you need to manually edit line?
Na gut, na gut
Ey, ey, könnte das mit cat
Er könnte das mit cat machen
Die Datei quasi ketten
Dann, ne, ne, könnte er nicht
Könnte er nicht
Ja doch, könnt ihr auslesen
Hier drin, ja
Aber das markieren wir, sind wir mal nicht so
Markieren wir das selbst mal
du md wasser also dass das hammer gemacht das hammer gemacht das hammer gemacht und das hammer
gemacht als nächstes dann haben wir dann haben wir noch das da gemacht und jetzt als nächstes
wir easy math machen das da soll jetzt als nächstes machen also oft geht's easy
math unser azubi auch gepackt scores txt run was bin ich da sehend ey du bist da sehend
Open Code bist du da sehend hier.
Open Code, beste.
Habe ich seit ein paar Tagen im Einsatz, ist mega nice.
Hat verschiedene Modi.
Ask, also das habe ich eingeführt.
Build, Plan und Ask.
Mit Build kannst du tatsächlich so Sachen machen wie,
füge mir eine neue Funktion hinzu für bla bla blub und sonst was.
Mit Plan kannst du Sachen, kannst du überlegen, wie war am besten, dass man das hinzufügt.
Und mit Ask stellst du halt Fragen.
Aber du kannst auch Sachen abspeichern, wenn du es ihm explizit sagst.
den modus habe ich hinzugefügt in der config datei und das ganze benutzt
aktuell glm 4.7 als model das ist über opencode gerade kostenlos wenn man damit
fein ist dass eine sache bei den china chinesen landen
Ja, klein R und eine Taste, dann replacet er das, hast du recht, ja.
Und Groß R, äh,
Im Vergleich zu, ich hab Cloud Code nie großartig ausprobiert.
ich benutze nur kostenlose sachen also ich denke mal cloud code ist bestimmt noch ein
bisschen polierter ja also open terminal ich glaube auch dass die ganz stark von cloud
inspiriert sind also wir sollen es gibt hier eine scores txt die besteht aus
line number und die zweite die zweite spalte ist ein score finde den durchschnittsscore
score also sprich das hier alles zusammenrechnen geteilt durch 100 use exactly two digits to the right
ok ok wie machen wir das also ich würde sagen chat ihr könnt ihr könnt mit raten ja
wir können ja vielleicht was anderes ausprobieren also wir cutten jetzt erstmal wieder anhand von
dem lehrzeichen jetzt das zweite feld dann ich weiß nicht ob das die eleganteste variant ist
dann peint man das nach xx dass man eine zeile draus machen dann wie place in wir
Leerzeichen
durch Plus.
Und das pipen wir jetzt nach PC.
520.4
Dann verschieben wir das Komma dahin
und schmeißen das weg.
5,20
müsste da rauskommen.
bei der Aufgabe.
Chat, was sagt ihr?
Oder wie würdet ihr es machen?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Bevor ich jetzt auf
Check my solution klicke,
ähm,
kriegt ihr nochmal
zwei, drei Minuten Zeit,
was zu überlegen.
Guck mal in den Chat.
Der TomRider hat eine Frage.
ich habe eine doof frage ich habe ein dual usb stick mit usb usb zu weihnachten der hat
laut hersteller nach 20 speicher als ich den stick am pc angeschossen habe und auf die eis
hat er nur das ist normal das ist jeder die frage wie die das rechnen die hersteller rechnen
natürlich so dass sie die größere zahl drauf schreiben können windows rechnet allerdings mit
mit was rechnet windows immer mit 1024 ich weiß nicht aber das ist so unterschiedliche
rechenart du wurdest nicht beschissen das ist normal das ist bei festplatten ssds genauso
ok ihr habt auch keine bessere idee wie wir es machen also dann schreiben wir doch mal
das hier in die Datei.
Solution.
5,20.
Check my solution.
Bam.
Geschafft.
Eats.
Ja dann.
Markieren wir das doch gleich mal als dann.
Easy math.
Guck mal.
Ich weiß, dass man es mit R machen kann.
So.
Okay, I have done.
Please pick a new random one.
Alexandria sollen wir jetzt machen.
Vanishing Backups.
alexandria der wenn ich in backups
kritiker backup kronjob er sei nicht stoppt working three days ago backup script ist
located at op back up backup punkt sh and short create daily backups in war
backup daily but no backups have been created recently aha looking at the
Okay, wir starten das schon mal.
Looking at the backup directory, you can see all backup files from a few days ago,
providing a system used to work.
However, there are no error emails, no obvious error logs,
and the cron service appears to be running normally.
Aha, da bin ich mal gespannt jetzt.
Fix all issues preventing the backups from running.
Bestimmt Berechtigung auf das Verzeichnis oder so.
fix all issues, prevent backups,
also backups are created
reliably.
Monka Englisch, Alter.
Gut, dann schauen wir doch mal.
Wo müssen wir hin?
War backups
daily?
Wir gucken
erst einmal kurz.
Achso, bestimmt als Route.
Grondtab minus l.
Oh, Grondtab
Syntax, Leute.
Ähm.
Das ist falsch.
Das ist Old Backup steht da drinnen.
Das muss nach
Backup
SH sein.
Was, was, was bedeuten
das hier? Läuft alle 5
Minuten? Ich kann, ey,
alle Cron Syntax.
Okay, wir fragen mal die AI.
Was bedeutet das?
Gron Syntax
Nein, warum nicht?
Das bedeutet, dass es jede 5 Minuten bedeutet.
Okay, chat, weil ihr es seid. Gron Tab Guru, bitte. Ist sie von dir die Seite?
Da kann man aber nicht einfach Copy-Paste und es suckt.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist mir lieber hier.
Also every five minutes.
Runs to pick.
Okay, also das ist schon mal falsch.
Es ist schon mal falsch, dass es
old backup ist.
Aber auf der anderen Seite,
wir führen das mal von Hand aus.
Backup und gucken mal, ob es funktioniert.
also hier haben wir backup aha guck mal hier haben wir ein skript eingetragen was es gar nicht gibt
die sagt zu komplex für mich ja
es ist nicht executable das ist das nächste ca mod plus x backup backup.sh
hören wir mal aus backup punkt sh backup already running log file exists log file löschen backup
successful dann sagen wir noch kontakt edit nano monka es alter na ok dann hier backup.sh
Yes.
So, gefixt.
Fixed all issues.
Preventing backups.
Test directory.
Backups dailies.
Ja.
13.18 ist von jetzt.
Ich würde sagen, wir haben es gefixt, oder?
Passt so
Hab ich irgendwas vergessen, Chat?
Backup wurde erstellt
Sieht gut aus, ja
Soll ich da irgendwas gucken?
Ich würde sagen, wir sind fertig
Ups
Bam
Geschafft
Next
Wie ist das, was wir gerade gemacht haben?
Alexandria
Okay
Next würde ich sagen
Oder, Chat, wir machen jetzt mal was anderes
Ich lasse es nicht random picken
Ihr dürft euch jetzt eins aussuchen
Aber das ist schwierig, ne?
Ihr wisst ja gar nicht, was es alles gibt
69 gibt es nicht
Doch gibt es.
Das müssen wir aber ausrechnen, was das ist.
Hong Kong sollen wir machen.
Hong Kong.
Can't write data into database.
Guck mal, da ist sogar ein Pro.
Ein Pro.
Oh, das ist ein schwieriges.
Wollen wir das machen, Chat?
Eine schwere Aufgabe, die nur für Pro-Subscriber
zur Verfügung steht.
also da kann es sein dass ich verkacke und nicht beim ersten durchlauf hin kriegt
mehr sei klar je nachdem was sie da wissen wollen also ich hab also als ich
das erste mal gemacht habe habe ich alle aufgaben gepackt aber bei zwei habe ich
mal den timeout gerissen also ist immer die frage je nachdem ob man davon ahnung
hat und ich okay postgres stellt kommt jetzt ran
also
die objektiv ist zu behaben zu inszenieren in ein existentes data base
ist es schon ist notspezifisch postkasten die dort nicht zu lau die
teile details about it kipp ausgerüstet auf port rights to this in
the data direction location of which to find it it's a process in your case
postkasten system ds unit with business and postgres okay also dass hier
ist der test als postgres user psql aus für ein insert was reinhauen da bin ich ja mal gespannt
wir haben 40 minuten zeit also das sollten wir hinkriegen
ich glaube man bekommt auch mehr zeit wenn man subscriber ist also nicht auf
Entschuldigung, das war jetzt kein Gebete für Subscriptions auf Twitch, wobei ich da natürlich nichts dagegen habe.
Ich meine Subscriber auf Set-Servers.
So.
Auf geht's. Wir werden direkt als Root eingeloggt.
Exzellent.
Home is not set.
Geht schon gut los.
Wo sind wir denn dann? In Slash.
Gibt es kein
Root oder was?
Ich habe den Home-Directory
nicht gesetzt. Das ist jetzt so schlimm.
Das da
schlägt fehl.
Connection to server on socket
failed. No such file or directory.
Das heißt Postgres läuft
nicht. Systemctl
status post
Moment.
Habe ich kein Auto-Complete?
Ich muss erst mal
mein Auto-Complete fixen.
Gut.
Ich muss
mir eine Becher zählen.
sourcen wir mal die basher c und für sourcen gibt es ein profile
source profile
Search history, okay, warte mal kurz.
Wie mir das gefällt, das ist mega nice.
Das ist Tür zu.
So.
Ich bin ja am Start.
Die Tür wurde nicht geschlossen, so geht es ja nicht.
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben jetzt?
Wir wollen gucken, warum Postcurs nicht läuft.
Warte mal.
Lass uns mal hier gucken nach...
Zack.
So, jetzt besser.
Es ist mega nice.
So, lass uns mal hier gucken nach...
ETC.
ASWD.
Root.
ist gleich und hat rupt kann homer verzeichnis gesetzt
export home gleich
Flash, gut.
System CTL.
List Units ist das, ne?
List Units.
Ah, hier.
So heißt das.
Ja, Promptail brauchen wir jetzt nicht wirklich.
Postgres QL at 14 main service.
Failed.
system zu gucken ob das normale an system ctl status postgresql ist active aber aus
kreuz at main service noch nicht warum nicht weil ob pg datamain ist not accessible oder
das nordex ist kann auch ein pitt feier okay fangen wir mal an also ob pg data main opt pg data
main gibt es nicht
ok
machen wir das mal als der user doch ja alle rechte richtig sind und man sehen
dass wir gesehen können dass wir hinkommen pg data mk dir main ok passt status
ja wieder konnte ich konnte kontrolle gedrückt
system ctl status postgres ok restart failed
wegen error user lib user lib postgres
was hat er jetzt für schmerzen opt pg datamain is not a database cluster directory
da fehlt ein mountpoint bestimmt
can't open pitfile
Tja, mit Datenbank bin ich nicht so der große Pro.
Was könnte denn das sein?
Try Hack Me oder Hack the Box gemacht.
Ne, haben wir auch nicht im Stream gemacht.
So, was könnte der jetzt hier für Schmerzen haben?
Ob PG Data Main ist not a database cluster?
Da ist doch irgendwas in der Config falsch.
Run Postgres.
Okay, das gucken wir auch mal kurz.
Nee, der hat Rechte hier drauf.
Das passt.
Also das ist es nicht.
Das liegt daran, dass Directory.opg.Data.Main.is.not.a.Database.Cluster.Directory.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was mir die Fehlermeldung sagen soll.
Aber es könnte sein, dass wir Main gar nicht hätten anlegen sollen von Hand.
Sondern.
Ach, hier liegt das. Guck mal.
Hier liegt das.
BTF? Falsches Verzeichnis.
Wale Postgres
liegt ne Main drinnen.
Das müssen wir rüber kopieren.
rm-rf
Opt
pgData main
Opt pgData
main
Löschen wir.
Jetzt gucken wir mal in die FS-Tab,
ob es da irgendwelche nicht gemauteten Sachen
gibt. Aha!
DF-H.
Das ist nicht gemountet.
Mount-A.
Achso, ja.
Oder auch nicht.
Chat, ich bin...
verwirrt.
Warum lässt sich da was nicht mounten?
Es gibt doch hier DEVXVDB.
Das gibt es bestimmt nicht.
Kann das sein?
Dass es das einfach nicht gibt?
Das gibt es nicht.
BLK-ID.
Was haben wir denn zu bieten?
SASNAME.
Ja.
Was haben wir gemountet?
N1P1.
15 haben wir gemountet.
14 haben wir hier noch zu bieten.
14.
Die hat aber kein Type.
Und das haben wir noch.
Das haben wir auch noch.
XFS ist das.
War das denn in der FS-Tab?
War das XFS?
XFS.
Okay, das heißt, wir brauchen höchstwahrscheinlich...
das da,
wo das gemountet wird.
ETC, FS-Tab.
Habe ich jetzt Mist getippt?
Oder stimmt das?
So, den Mountpoint müssen wir anpassen.
Jetzt mounten wir nochmal.
Schon besser.
Dann funktioniert es.
Moment.
Mount.
Def.
Nach MNT.
Geht doch.
Ja, U-Mount. Warum hat das denn hier sich nicht
mounten lassen?
FSTab.
OPG-Data.
Warum hat es das jetzt nicht
mounten lassen? Das ist doch leer.
Opt.
PG-Data.
Hä?
Okay, whatever.
Chat, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Der...
Der unmountet das immer wieder.
Was ist denn das?
Keck, wait.
So, pass mal auf, wir bescheißen den jetzt.
Wir chibaten den jetzt.
Wir sagen Mount.
Nach MNT.
Weil das geht ja offensichtlich.
Das geht ja offensichtlich.
Vielleicht ist es wirklich ein Unmount.
den cronjob
wiki beten den jetzt ein mnt liegt es ja da so
oder ein system detail das kann schon sein dass es immer an mountet wird was
ist das denn wir machen jetzt link genau wir machen jetzt link nach opt pg data
also machen jetzt ein link lm-s main nach dahin pg opt pg data schon haben wir
den link das ist gut das ist gut passt restart postgres was was hat er jetzt für schmerzen
Was? Opt PG Data Main ist on Access?
Habe ich mich vertan?
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Opt PG Data.
Ups.
Was habe ich denn da gemacht?
WTF?
LN-S
Warte mal, warte mal.
Das war doch so rum, oder?
MNT, Main.
Dahin.
Jetzt habe ich es richtig.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Da habe ich eben Mist getippt.
Restart geht wieder nicht.
Warum nicht?
Could not create log file post master pit.
No space left on device.
Alter
No space left
Ja, es ist 100%
Was hat man hier in MNT? Alles liegen
File, Backup, okay
Delete me
69 Bytes
Was steht denn da drin?
Excellent
Delete me
So, komm, wir löschen die
Wobei, ganz ehrlich
Die Backups lösche ich mal nicht
die braucht man bestimmt noch die werde ich mal nicht proaktiv hier löschen so
restart main immer noch nicht status was hat er jetzt wieder verschmerzt
could not create no space left on the earth
tja dann müssen wir doch die backups löschen so wie es aussieht
rm pfeil 1 was steht denn da so drin abbrechen
so
restart
es ist gestartet es ist gestartet
aus kreis
wir haben es gepackt postkurs läuft ins auch funktioniert check my solution easy easy
easy easy
gepackt
so
was war jetzt als nächstes ihr könnt ihr könnt eins vorschlagen wenn ihr wollt macht ich poste
mal die Seite im Chat, wo die Szenarien
drauf sind. Ihr könnt euch eins raussuchen,
was wir als nächstes machen wollen. Und wenn
die Leute sich so halbwegs einig sind,
dann mach ich das. In der Zwischenzeit lass ich von der AI
nochmal eins picken.
Immer Backup löschen, damit es startet.
Genau. Backup ist eh
overrated. Wenn das System ordentliche
Verfügbarkeit hat und nie kaputt geht,
dann braucht man natürlich auch keine Backups.
Und wenn keiner Blödsinn
damit anstellt und Sachen löscht oder so.
Backups ist genauso overrated wie Kommentare oder Dokumentation oder Tests.
Das braucht man alles nicht. Es muss einfach immer fehlerfrei funktionieren und keiner darf Fehler bei der Bedienung machen.
Dann brauchst du alles andere nicht.
Ganz einfach.
Genau, null Fehlermethode.
Also wie gesagt, ich bin auch dafür.
Ich sollte Coaching anbieten dafür.
Weil offensichtlich ist das natürlich im Stream bei mir natürlich auch immer der Fall.
Please pick me a new random scenario.
Was kommt jetzt?
Word Histogram.
marrakesch das soll jetzt machen wird histogrammen also ein ende feil frankenstein txt des second
most frequent word and save it uppercase das second most ja gut das ist doch im endeffekt
fast das gleiche wie wir es vorher auch gemacht haben oder einfach wörter unique
minus c
das müsste doch so gehen
wobei das ein bisschen schwieriger sein müsste weil das ist ein medium
Oh man, es geht ja noch weiter.
A word is a string of characters
separated by space.
Ja, ja, okay.
Disregard case. Ach so.
The, the, the
is the same word.
Ah, das wird noch ein bisschen
komplizierter.
Also disregard plurals k k's.
Okay.
Oh, keine Ahnung, wie man das macht.
Ich check die Aufgabe schon gar nicht richtig, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man das am besten macht.
Da stehe ich jetzt auf dem Schlauch.
So, wir haben hier eine
Cat.
Frankenstein TXC.
Okay.
Also Chat, wenn ihr Ideen habt,
mal hier. Da fällt mir jetzt gerade nichts ein.
also case insensitive das ganze schon mal betrachten
seht magic ja wahrscheinlich also erstmal müssen wir das ganze ding in lower case
Lowercase formatieren.
Bashed
File to all lowercase.
Irgendwas mit tr wahrscheinlich.
Ja, hier.
tr upper to lower, genau.
Also cat
das nach. Jetzt kommt mir
keiner mit useless use of cat. Das ist einfach
viel einfacher zu tippen so.
Blub.txt
less blub.txt
So, jetzt haben wir
alles in lowercase.
kein einziges uppercase Wort mehr, das ist schon mal gut, das macht es einfacher. So und jetzt
Word as a string separated by space or null and, ja klar, oder Punkte, oder Punkte, natürlich,
ja...
Also Punkte...
Punkte soll ich auch löschen, hä?
Ich sollte Punkte...
Okay.
Punkte müssen...
ersetzt werden...
mit Leerzeichen.
Punkte ersetzen mit Leerzeichen?
Och.
Äh.
So.
Oh shit, ich depp.
Ich hab in die gleiche Datei geschrieben,
aus der ich gelesen hab.
Plop 2 TXT.
So, hier haben wir jetzt keine Punkte mehr drin.
Dafür Leerzeichen.
Okay.
Kann man das einfach X-Arten?
Nee, oder?
Das geht nicht so einfach.
So, also wir haben jetzt hier eine Datei mit Wörtern.
Ja und, was ist das hier?
Mit den Klammern drumherum?
Das soll der mithelen quasi dann im Endeffekt.
So, und wie machen wir das jetzt?
Da machen wir eine Schleife drüber, hä?
Oh, das ist aber halt lahm,
es fuck.
Du, Echo, I, dann...
Komma? Von Komma stand da nix, oder?
Stand da irgendwas von einem Komma?
Komma juckt nicht, ne?
Ach doch, Symbols.
Punkt, Komma, Doppel...
Ach so.
Okay, das heißt, das müssen wir auch noch
machen.
Seht,
minus i,
plupp 2,
wir replacen alle
Sud.
Wir replacen
alle Punkte,
das haben wir schon gemacht,
wir replacen alle Semikolons,
durch space wir replizieren alle doppel punkte durch space und wir replizieren alle demikon durch
space
ok nichts mehr da und jetzt ist gleich hier nochmal ein schleife drüber ok gut jetzt
kriegen wir jedes einzelne wort raus und auch so komische dinger das sorten wir jetzt
Ja, das ist egal.
Das juckt nicht.
Das sollten wir nicht filtern.
Also, Digital Card Plurals,
K und K ist das different.
Achso.
Wie mache ich denn das am besten?
Müsste ich gucken?
Welches wort mit s endet aber es gibt ja auch es gibt auch legit wörter die mit s enden
Ach nee moment k n k sa different for district cards okay also egal muss man sich nicht muss man sich nicht drum kümmern
Okay
Und noch mal einen sort hinten drauf
Ist das meist benutzte wort das problem sollte nicht
doch oder ist das das meist zwar acht zweitmeister end und das in uppercase
also end my solution
Boah, Quatsch!
EASY!
Easy.
E-e-e-easy.
Easy clap.
Eigentlich solltest du vorher alles zu Lowercase casten, hab ich doch gemacht.
Hab ich doch gemacht.
Okay, was...
Was habt ihr eben gesagt, soll ich machen?
Irgendwas Hack-Webserver oder sowas?
Das da?
Hack-Webserver.
60 Minuten.
Alter.
dann machen wir das was hier random gepickt wird
60 minuten okay zeigt noch mal her dass das muss ich mir muss ich mir mal in ruhe angucken
wer ist es sieg wird dort in der file das local apache web server
kennt wo weit findet sie könnt and have it as home admin secret txt
der server ist
user ist not in sudoers ok kein zu access
ok und was was moment was ist jetzt was ist jetzt das ziel der ist das secret
dort in der feier okay das secret and having as home admin secret txt feier
keine ahnung da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
habe ich ja mal gespannt jetzt was da raus kommt bei achtung flashback an
Ach ne, mein Darkreader.
Ha, mein Darkreader hat's abgemildert.
Ja.
Wie sieht's aus?
Hallo?
Was hat die AI für uns als nächstes?
Salta, nicht Santa.
Salta.
Docker-Container-One-Start.
Gut, das machen wir dann danach.
Guck mal, die ist sogar so schlau und macht dieses Docker-Symbol dahinter.
Auf geht's.
Also, wir haben einen Webserver.
Her local host.
an authorized index html server code not only for that you are authorized to access
the documentary quest wrong credentials browser das haus okay wie geht das back mit kölner hat
http admin at 123456.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Doppelpunkt.
Aber so wie ich es gemacht habe, müsste es auch gehen.
Gut, also.
Das fand ich schon immer nett.
Haben wir Zugriff auf irgendwelche Logs?
Okay, Zugriff auf Logs haben wir.
Errorlog.
User Admin not found.
Äh, die Frage ist, wie der User heißt.
Wollen wir hier?
Wir gucken mal in Access Logs, ob da vielleicht schon was von früher drin steht.
Ne, nix.
Wollen wir Access Log 1?
Steht da noch ein User drin?
Was ist das denn?
AWS?
PHP Info?
What?
Was bin ich sehend?
AWS Credentials?
Nee, das kommt doch von irgendwas anderem, oder?
das ist noch irgendein Überbleibsel.
Gibt es die Dateien?
Ich habe keine Hutrechte. Ich kann da nicht reingucken.
Wa, www.
Ach, Moment.
Da darf ich reingucken?
Webfile?
Ah, Access denied.
Okay.
Webfile.
Curl?
Hier User.
Admin.
Okay, nee, das ist schon mal nett.
Aber wo kommt denn das hier her?
Dieses AWS Credentials?
Das gibt es ja gar nicht.
Okay, wie komme ich da jetzt dran?
Netzstat?
Mal gucken, ob da noch mehr irgendwie läuft, außer auf Port 80.
Äh, das da läuft auf Port 80, das ist irgendwas anderes.
Was haben wir denn hier für User drin?
Admin?
Ich meine, das ist für ein Apache egal.
Das steht da nicht hier drin.
ETC Apache 2.
Ich darf da reingucken oder was?
In die Dateien?
HTPathWD.
Da habe ich aber keinen Zugriff drauf.
Doch!
Moment, da habe ich Zugriff drauf?
Ja, dann.
hackerman modus aktiviert würde ich sagen
cp kopiert kopieren wir uns die mal kurz
da ist der ht passwd
da sind auf jeden fall schon mal user carlos carlos
ok so jetzt ist die frage wie man hashtag irgendwie benutzt
es hat es hat der passwd keine ahnung aus dem kopf
das heißt es minus 1500 was
jetzt moment ich weiß nicht wie das funzt da fragen wir doch jetzt mal meiste chat
gpt antworten wie ich kann man hier unser gott at at pass willi fall and one to break
der passwort hash with hashcat auto du
hast wie macht man das ich bin da
überhaupt nicht blut irgendwie in
wo das der namen zu die karte passwerte
files 1000 m 500 ich mich checks wie
Wie jetzt? Was? HASH M 1500?
Und dann?
Ach, nur den Hash.
No Hash loaded.
Okay, aber so funktioniert das auch.
Und jetzt brauche ich irgendwelche Hash-Files?
Hash-Cat?
No hashes loaded
Aber guck mal, der checkt das
Token length exception
Also im Endeffekt sage ich jetzt
Cut
Htpasswd
Dann nehme ich mir nur den
Warte mal, warte mal
Das hier ist die
Das ist halt die Frage
Ist das ein Salt?
Oder ist das die Methode
Wie es verschlüsselt wurde
Ok
HTPASSWD
Aufbau
Ähm
Feels
Username, Hash, Passwort
Ok, also
Okay, was sagt das Ding hier?
AT-Pass-WD
Ah, April 1
Apache MD5
Es ist nicht 1500
ich habe keine über den scheiß benutzt
ach da muss nur der herr schreien also im endeffekt im endeffekt so war es dann hier
also quasi nur den part also quasi so
oder muss es ein pfeil sein eschpunkt txt
Esch.txt
Alter, wie funzt denn das Scheißding?
Oder ist es
Esch2.txt
5x2 TXT.
Machen wir mal Carlos weg.
Und den anderen Kram lassen wir da.
Nox Twitch, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog.
Aha.
Okay, jetzt macht er was.
Jetzt macht er was.
Man muss vorne noch das Format mit reinpacken.
Hackerman-Modus gestartet.
mal gucken was die ei sagt
extra chest just a hash porsche part after username okay haben wir auch jetzt gemacht
schuster mode apache md 5 1600 habe gemacht brandtisch kett ja im prinzip haben wir uns
selbst so zusammen gewurschtelt user shareworth list
mein server ist jetzt habe ich ihn gelegt auch noch shit
Aber das irgendwie jetzt kaputt gemacht
Es kennt minus 1600 ok t mox haben wir nicht es geht minus 1600
Und jetzt noch mal
Esch 2
Muss man da noch irgendwelche Word Lists angeben?
User Share Word Lists?
Rules?
Da war eine...
Da war eine Word List.
Hashcat?
Was ist da?
Nee, oder?
Irgendwas über Wordlist.
Wie geht das?
Minus
User, Share
und Wordlist.
Lassen wir einfach nochmal.
sind halt so wenn man sie tools nicht großartig verwendet hat ein platzen schimmer
in john liegt da was ach so
Das ist aber ein anderes Tool.
Passwort LST.
Kann man das da jetzt angeben?
So.
relativ bargetta runterladen ich glaube nicht dass man hier ans internet kommt
ich glaube wir haben das vorhin schon richtig gemacht warum brauchen wir hier
so lang bei Initializing
bekehlt.
Brauchen wir zu viel CPU-Zeug
oder was?
Was am I doing wrong?
Out of RAM.
jetzt also das von steven ich kann man das irgendwie einschränken oder so ok
benutzen wir benutzen einfach ein anderes der tools was die die da liegen
Wir probieren mal ein anderes Tool
Hier
Wir haben hier Hashcat, Hydra
Und John Ripper Binaries
John
Und wo liegt das unter Run?
Ah ja, okay.
Passwort-Files.
Hash2.
TXT.
Charlotte ist das Passwort?
Oder was?
Ist das das Passwort?
Oder was anderes?
Minus Minus Show.
Charlotte.
Okay, Curl.
Curl, Local Host.
Ähm.
Carlos.
Minus U.
Charlotte.
Geht.
Und jetzt gab es hier, wie hieß dieses Ding?
Ähm.
War www.html.
web file web file
aha
müssen wir in datei um um leiten punkt bin ja
das blutpunkt bin secret txt secret txt
Strings.
Secrets.txt
Curl.
Secret.txt
Not found.
File.
Blub.bin
Ach, das ist ein Zip.
Blub.
Charlotte.
Oh, das muss ich jetzt nochmal
crack so.
Okay, das ist...
Okay, okay. John.
Run.
Kann man das einfach so angeben?
Ähm.
Blub.
Punkt bin.
Ne.
Ähm.
John.
Ripper.
Zip.
File.
Hashcat
Hashcat Zip
File
Oder kann man hier einfach sagen
Hashcat
Nee
Jus schon zu gut vor passwort
das china chinesen model hat damit keine probleme chat gpt ist wieder so korrekt
Also was?
Extract
You need to extract the hash first
Zip to John
Was ist das da drauf?
Nee, oder?
Ist das hier?
Und da?
Zip
Zip to John
Okay, Zip to
Okay, okay
Also was soll man machen?
Zip to John
Zip Hash TXT
oder wie auch immer
ähm, hash
hash, ne, ähm
blub, blub.bin
aha, da ist es
und jetzt hier Hash.txt
John ausführen
mit Hash.txt
Andes
ist das Passwort, Andes
Anzip
Andes
Alles
Secrets TXT
Da haben wir es
Wir haben es rausgekriegt
Easy
Und was sollen wir jetzt genau machen
Dann
Moment, der hat vergessen, dass ich es gestartet habe.
Secrets TXT?
Note that in this server...
Okay, habe ich das irgendwie aus Versehen geschlossen vorhin?
Ah, geil.
Und dann soll ich...
Okay, Test.
Test.
Hier.
Returns.
Richtig.
Passt.
Geschafft.
Ich kann jetzt nicht auf...
Market.
Secrets.
TXT.
Wir kopieren uns das jetzt.
Sagen wir nochmal Run.
Hier hat das.
Ja und wie kann ich jetzt weitermachen an der Stelle?
Das checkt er nicht.
Destroy.
Ich will es aber erledigt haben.
Waren wir das nochmal auf
Und dann speichern wir das hier einfach
In Secrets.txt und drücken auf
Auf lösen
Wir haben es ja gemacht
Okay, das war in der Tat schwieriger als gedacht
Was aber auch daran liegt, dass ich
Von den Hackerman-Tools, keine Ahnung
Hab, muss ich alles googeln
Übrigens, was ich lustig finde, Puzzlemeister
Dankeschön für den Sub, gar nicht gesehen
Exzellente Subscription
HiFat, IQ steigt für den gesamten Chat dadurch
Was ich aber auch witzig finde ist, ChatGPT beantwortet sowas nicht. Das China-Chinesen-Model GLM 4.7 hat überhaupt keine Probleme, solche Anfragen zu beantworten.
Also ich finde die Server fixen
Szenarios besser als die
Hexroar Szenarios
Okay
Okay was für
Wie wäre es mit dem nächsten
Tigoni
gucken wir schon mal rein die go nie patch and pray moment das ist das vorletzte vor
vorletzte in hart das ist wahrscheinlich tatsächlich relativ schwierig
ja ich hab's ich hab ich habe ein clip hat manager ich kann nichts verlieren secret.txt
check my solution ich habe gebraucht 19 sekunden okay das war jetzt ein bisschen beschiss
tigoni patch and pray was erwartet uns denn hier access e mail developer wants to upgrade
der stateful application des application handels der archives backups das ist ein
kuba nederstelz application tigoni ist die platt und kuba netz in der default
namespace der application server ist die platt helm ist zwar standard aber ich
muss immer kotzen wenn ich helden sehe der command der used his helm install
tigoni jahre gut es klingt was abkürzt igoni application 2 v 2.0.0 der image
already exist in the local repository debug and help the developer fix any issues with the upgrade
every time 1.0 is launched the archiving code starts on a clean state okay gucken wir uns das einfach mal an
run
Ich hab ne Idee.
Ich hab ne Idee,
wie wir das cheesen können.
Lass mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Lass mal funktionieren.
Ich versuch das mal zu cheesen.
Vielleicht geht's das auch nicht.
Also.
Cube CTL get Pots minus A.
Tigoni, da ist er, running, ist auch alles okay.
Cube CTL,
Logs,
ah, ich hab immerhin,
immerhin Auto Complete
am Start. Tigoni,
Tigoni Server is ready to serve,
building archive, gut, soll er mal machen.
Also, wir probieren es jetzt mal,
wir probieren es jetzt mal zu cheesen.
Der will eine Version 2 haben.
Was ist denn der Test?
Test,
Tigoni Port with Version 2,
version 2 runs correctly its endpoint health displays server version 2 also
get services gibt keine services
port 3000 okay das heißt wir müssen kann man uns da rein exekten
Cube CTL?
Schon ein paar Wochen nichts mehr gemacht.
Wie war das jetzt? Cube CTL
Run?
It?
Ne, ähm.
Ne, exec. Exec, nicht run.
Exec?
Pots?
Tigoni?
Äh,
BinSH?
Ne, oh, fuck.
Wie war das?
Bin Bash?
Unable to start container process.
Bin Bash. Ja, okay, das gibt's nicht.
Ja gut, Pech gehabt.
Dann nicht.
Dann execken wir uns da nicht rein, würde ich sagen.
Bin SH gibt's auch nicht.
Na gut.
Nee, glaube ich nicht.
Glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, das ist einfach so gebaut, das Image.
So, warte mal. Ich versuche das jetzt mal zu cheesen.
Cube CTL Edit.
Ist das ein Deployment?
Nee.
Was ist denn das?
Jetpods?
Das hier...
Was ist denn das?
StatefulSet ist das, weil das ein Null hinten dran hat.
StatefulSet.
JupCTL Edit.
Äh, ne.
StatefulSet.
Tigoni.
Image.
So, das ist jetzt mein Cheese-Versuch.
Tigoni.
V2.
okay was genau hat man da jetzt gemacht
das war ein schießversuch jetzt schau mal terminating ja ein bisschen schneller
kuba nides admin check kann man ausführen
guck mal rein
localhost 3 3 3 3 hältst
guck mal, ne, das ist ja hier
richtig Highspeed gerade
ah, jetzt hat er neu gestartet
ah, ne, das
fandst du nicht, shit, ich hätte gedacht
wir könnten einfach das austauschen, oder geht's
no
fail to open archive
zip, not a valid zip file
Was?
Okay, also einfach die Sache
Investion 2 austauschen
hat nicht funktioniert.
Das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach.
Ich habe gedacht, wir könnten das vielleicht schießen.
Okay, dann müssen wir uns das Ganze jetzt mal...
Okay, Helm, List, minus A.
Okay, also lasst mal kurz hier gucken.
Application is deployed on default.
The command they use is Helm install.
Upgrade to the image already exists in the local repository.
Debug and help the developer fix any issues with upgrade.
Every time it's launched, archiving code starts on a clean state.
Ist das relevant?
Okay, dann werden wir jetzt mal...
Ich würde gerne in das Helm-Chart reingucken.
Guck mal hier, Debug-Pod.yaml.
Ah, sehr schön, wir kriegen einen Debug-Pod.
Optigoni.
Okay, das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Ich würde sagen, als erstes, sagen wir mal, Helm install...
Install. Wo liegt denn das Helm-Chart überhaupt?
Liegt das hier irgendwo lokal?
Charts.
Tigoni.
Values YAML.
Ah, hier. Okay.
Damit kann man das installen.
Tag 2.
Opt Tigoni.
Dann installieren wir jetzt einmal korrekt.
Helm.
Uninstall.
Tigoni.
Helm.
Install.
Minus, minus.
Upgrade.
War das nicht so?
Oder war es Helm upgrade?
Minus, minus install.
Ja, so war es so.
Wie muss man das jetzt nochmal installieren?
So, ne?
Ach ne.
Release Name Tigoni.
Das da. Okay.
Get Ports.
Ending.
Error.
Okay.
Cube CTL.
Describe.
Tigoni, ne, ähm, Stateful Z, Tigoni, was hat der für Schmerzen?
Ähm.
Also da ist nix.
Get Events.
Da ist jetzt nix kaputt gegangen.
Also, dass er irgendwas nicht pullen kann oder so.
daran liegt es nicht.
Also das Funst.
Dann müssen wir nochmal in die Logs reingucken.
Logs.
Fail to open archive.
Opt Tigoni.
Arsch, Hals, Zipp, no,
Falsch, Pfeiler, Directory.
Ja, was weiß ich, was die da treiben.
Also,
das dürfte schon mal das Problem sein.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht,
was die da machen
in ihrer Anwendung.
Hm.
Dann sollten wir doch mal den
Debug-Pot starten, würde ich sagen.
Starten wir mal
den Debug. Ich gucke mal kurz
in das Chart rein.
Templates.
EVC.
Ja gut, das hat ja offensichtlich funktioniert.
gibt ctl get pv get pvc das ist baut das heißt es ist auch geklebt von dem pott also dass da
dritte gemonte das muss müsste eigentlich so passen was haben wir denn hier sonst templates
stateful set service account also da habe ich jetzt auch keine er ist irgendwie gesehen dass
dass der das nicht starten könnte.
Gucken wir mal kurz rein.
Service Account.
Ah, das wird schon...
Hör mal, das wird schon passen.
Weil sonst hätte das Ding...
Sonst hätte das Ding ja geschrieben, er kann nicht starten und sowas.
Ähm...
Dann bleibt ja eigentlich nur noch StatefulSet,
wo wir reingucken können.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine ultra hässliche Helm-Config wieder?
Ich muss eh schon kotzen,
wenn ich Helm sehe.
Aber das ist Template in Template.
Das ist ja ganz besonders schrecklich.
Moment, Containerport 3000.
Soll das auf 333 laufen?
Ah ne, Health.
Der Health Endpunkt.
Wann das hier irgendwo?
Was sagt denn hier?
Hörl?
Warte mal.
Check.sh
333 ok ist richtig ist richtig also port stimmt
Welt zu connect dass der sinn ist nicht gesteckt ist abgekackt beim starten
Ja genau das genau das ist das chat
gubern jammel in your jammel oder jason in your jammel oder template in your jammel
sieht man da ist da da probst du das kommt dann irgendwelche probleme mit seinem tipp
ich meine ich habe ja keine ahnung was die anwendung macht so wir starten jetzt mal den
Debug Pod.
Cube CTL.
Apply minus F.
Debug Pod.
Okay.
Pod is created.
Exec.
Pods.
Alpine.
Bin Bash.
Bin.
SH.
Ha, da sind wir.
APK.
install, haben wir da Zugriff ins Internet?
Ach ne, add ist es.
Wir haben Zugriff aufs Internet.
Easy.
Okay, und jetzt haben wir hier gemountet.
Opt.
Opt Tigoni.
Da liegt halt nichts drin.
Soll ich da jetzt mal eine ZIP-Datei erstellen?
Einfach random.
Archiv.zip
Da hat er doch immer...
keine ahnung was hier okay mama einfach hier touch 1
wie geht das
echo echo
Oh, beste Datei.
Äh, was weiß ich?
Archiv.zip
Alter, wie funzt der Scheiß nochmal?
Okay, so rum war es.
Archiv.zip
Ach, Moment.
Ich hab's jetzt gezippt.
Vielleicht hätte ich's auch gezippen müssen.
Na, schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal in die Logs rein, was das Tigoni-Ding macht.
Tigoni, lüg nicht.
Lüg nicht.
Das Zip ist jetzt da.
Aschi...
Punkt Zip.
Das lügt.
Starte ich doch mal neu.
Ansonsten muss ich dich deleten.
Delete Pod.
Tigoni.
Archive corrupted.
Cleaner war der Zip.
Okay. Immerhin.
Immerhin eine ordentliche
Meldung. Immerhin eine ordentliche Meldung.
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe
Wir müssen V1 starten
Warten bis V1 durch ist
Und dann upgraden auf V2
Okay
Opt
Tigoni
RMA KFZ
Also
Dann gehen wir nochmal in die Charts rein
an install dann in die values jammer wir wollen version 1 noch mal installieren
das ist ja auch eine grausame upgrade install tigoni pots müsste gleich wieder laufen
Ja, auf, mach hinne
Nicht so viel rumpenden, sondern starten
Auf was pendigt das denn eigentlich jetzt?
tigoni was los jetzt das kreis
hey schedule nots ab was der cluster kaputt gegangen jetzt irgendwie meine
Kubernetes-Nodes sind kaputt.
Ich glaube, das gehört nicht
zum Teil
der Übung.
Wobei, der ist ready.
Der ist doch ready.
Ist doch alles gut.
Ah!
Persistent Volume und Tigone ist being deleted.
Es dauert noch.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Der wartet noch, bis das PVC und so gelöscht ist.
Das dauert einfach noch ein bisschen.
Guck, der sagt hier,
Persistent Volume from Tigoni is being deleted.
PVC?
Terminating.
ich an ins ich an install noch mal
das gehört glaube ich nicht zur übung
übernähtes graben so also irgendwie löscht er den kram ich warum du nicht
der löscht das pvc es ist schon die ganze zeit in terminating müssen wir jetzt irgendwelche
final also ach so weil man alpine port noch läuft ach so ja der greift darauf zu ja ja
ctl elite minus f die backport ja das ist es omega lull
ja kuba netz
habe ich irgendwie zerstört
da warten wir mal ab
Okay, guck, PVC sind schon mal weg
Und es ist alles weg
Okay, nice
Jetzt können wir den Kram nochmal installieren
Charts, Tigoni
Install
Wunderbar
Get Pots
Building Archive, okay
Apply
Bash
installiere bash mal wieder das riecht durch hier mit opt opt tigoni
kummer archive ist null beiz das ist doch garantiert so nicht so nicht gedacht
das ist das ist schon jetzt kaputt das archiviert nicht richtig
ok wir müssen mal kurz was machen so domino sie ab install thema
Logs.
Die 1er Version ist schon kaputt.
Building Archive.
Ja, ja, der ist jetzt schon irgendwie kaputt.
der V1er ist schon
kaputt.
Der erstellt da nichts.
Oder ist ein leeres Archiv
okay?
Ist ein leeres Archiv okay?
Weil wenn ein leeres Archiv okay ist,
können wir jetzt einfach mal upgraden.
Probieren wir das mal.
Charts, Tigoni, Upgrade, okay Helm, Install, minus minus Up, Up, Up, nein es ist Helm Upgrade,
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Tigoni.
WCTL Get Pods.
So, jetzt haben wir geupgradet.
Ne, haben wir nicht.
Vergessen.
Ich habe vergessen, die Version anzupassen.
V2.
Jetzt aber.
Terminating.
Gucken wir mal.
Das PVC sollte er jetzt ja da lassen.
In 24 Minuten muss ich weg, Leute.
Wir schauen jetzt gerade mal hier rein.
CubeCTL Exec.
Pots, Alpine, Spin, Bash.
Wie sieht es denn in Optigoni jetzt aus?
Immer noch 0.
Aber was ist es denn für ein Zip?
Pile not found.
Wenn ich abt.
Er ist ein Empty-Zip.
Ja, auch geil.
Aber ich will wissen, was das für eine...
Na gut, es ist gar nichts.
Es ist null Bytes.
Crash-Loop-Backoff.
Okay.
Ich habe noch nicht so genau gecheckt, was die genau wollen.
Also da ist es schon eine Weile.
Die Datei ist auch da.
Und was sagen jetzt die Logs?
Typ CTL, Logs.
Boni.
Not a valid zip file.
Also funzt die...
Die Anwendung funzt schon mal nicht. Die Einser.
Die Einser ist schon kaputt.
Ja, also das mit dem Backup ist schon kaputt.
Trotzdem müssen wir nochmal in die Charts gucken.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt zu den Entwicklern gehen und sagen, was macht das Ding denn eigentlich?
Es gibt ja eigentlich nur das hier, wo was drin sein könnte.
W491A
Eigenschaft für den Sub
Pog Subscription
Mehr EQ für den Chat
Notes.txt
Geil
Also ich verstehe nicht so genau, was sie von mir wollen, ehrlich gesagt.
Woher soll ich wissen, warum das Ding kein Zip schreibt?
Keine Ahnung, was die Anwendung macht.
Relaxed Critical Information.
Dann sage ich, da läuft dein Service halt nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das...
Also jetzt wüsste ich echt nicht, was ich machen soll.
Also wir müssen auf jeden Fall nochmal downgraden
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall nochmal downgraden
Weil
Es funzt
Das 1er schreibt schon keine Backups
Das hat es wieder nicht gecheckt.
UCTL delete
port
Tigoni.
Okay.
So, jetzt haben wir wieder Version 1 am Start.
Building Archive.
Aber der bildet ja nichts.
Der macht ja nichts.
Weil wenn man hier guckt,
das ist immer 0 Byte.
Keine Ahnung, was das Ding macht.
Wo soll ich das wissen?
Legt der Source-Code hier irgendwie rum oder so?
Ich sehe da auch keine Fehler.
Also hier weiß ich nicht, was ich machen soll.
Wie viel Zeit haben wir noch? 12 Minuten?
Keine Ahnung. Gucken wir uns mal die Clues an.
Abgehörte Application.
Das haben wir gemacht.
Haben wir gemacht.
Ne, die Upgrade ist nicht
successful.
Fail to open.
Not a valid zip file.
Genau.
So weit war ich auch schon.
die backports ja haben wir auch gemacht
haben wir das haben wir genau das haben wir auch gemacht
to check if the file exit ja ja das haben wir alles gemacht haben wir alles gemacht
tutscher gibt der podcast der fall mit skipsen das haben wir auch gemacht
it seems the archive ist feier ist sommer korab weist der angst korruptet
after up in den net after upgrade vor dem upgrade auch schon korruptet das war immer null
redeploy 1.0
ja okay denn abgabe des time check the logs erste post terminate
8 der beendet sich nicht richtig oder was
Okay, mal gucken, was rauskommt
Increase determination, grace power
Ach, das ist das Problem
Da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen
Okay, also
Delete Tigoni
Helm
Delete
Tigoni
Ähm
Templates
Irgendwas mit
Craze
Schatter.
Ne, wo steht das drin?
Ne.
Stateful Set, Jamel.
Da bin ich doch drin.
Ach ne, Moment.
Falsches Ding geguckt hier.
Zeile 32.
Ne.
Hä?
Wo steht das überhaupt?
Grace?
Das gibt es hier überhaupt nicht drin.
Das was hier in der Lösung steht gibt es nicht.
Ja aber gibt es nicht.
Ist doch da hier craze?
Und angeblich in Zeile 32.
Aber in Zeile 32 ist nichts.
oder soll ich das reinschreiben oder soll ich das reinschreiben an der stelle aber
da steht in christ da würde ich sagen das ist schon drin
dass hier und der stelle rein
und wie 40
values
1 ok install
ach so
delete
ctl delete minus f debug pod
aber das ist schon merkwürdig also eine anwendung die erst beim runterfahren ihre
loks in nicht ihre loks ihre backups flashed lascht das schon ziemlich
bepegel ja da wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen ich habe alles gemacht bis zu
also ein prinzip das hier auch ja auch auf die lösung bin ich gekommen
war schwierig
so jetzt habe ich geupdatet
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das wieder läuft.
Tigoni ist immer noch pending.
Warum?
Persistent Volume Claim not found.
Achso, ich muss das, ich muss das glaube ich nochmal
delete nur nochmal neu anlegen install
ok jetzt wieder am start so und jetzt cubectl delete port tigoni
so und jetzt soll das ganze 45 sekunden brauchen moment moment moment moment
wenn ich das die liete ich kann dann fängt er wieder von vorne an
aber er hängt schon mal 45 sekunden schon mal ganz gut das ist das problem
ich darf das nicht die lieten weil jetzt fängt er wieder von vorne an klein wir
können bei der gelegenheit war gerade dabei sind wir können noch mal die die
den Debug-Pot starten. Logs, ja ja, kubectl apply minus f Debug-Pot, exec, ash, opt, opt tigoni,
so null byte und jetzt sagen wir ihm values 2 minus minus upgrade gibt ctl get pods
so jetzt hängt er in terminating für 45 sekunden
Und er sollte hoffentlich jetzt das gleiche in das Archiv-Punkt-Zip schreiben.
Warten wir mal, hoffentlich packt er das von der Zeit her noch, ja.
Okay, Container creating.
Error.
Immer noch?
Hä?
Okay, keine Ahnung. Das ist ein dummes
Das ist eine dumme
Übung.
Obwohl ich
hab doch die Solution direkt befolgt jetzt.
Naja.
Gut.
Nicht gelöst. Verkackt.
Destroy Server.
Bam.
Ähm. Ich hab jetzt gar nicht
abgehakt, was wir schon gemacht
haben vorher.
Wir haben
Hack-Web-Server gemacht.
das haben wir gemacht
alexandria haben wir gemacht habe ich abgang wir haben noch ein bisschen wir haben noch
mehr gemacht aber das habe ich jetzt verpeilt ich werde es zuerst ansehen
was man wissen wo es nicht wo wir gewesen sind das letzte mal
Ich kann gerade noch mal gucken, Szenarios.
Also, Alexandria.
Das haben wir...
Hab ich das gehört?
Hab ich abgehakt?
Mara.
Mara, das haben wir noch gemacht.
Okay.
Hongkong?
Haben wir noch gemacht?
Vanishing Backup haben wir auch noch gemacht.
Das habe ich schon abgehakt.
Okay, nee, dann haben wir jetzt alles.
Das, was wir heute gemacht haben.
Also das Kubernetes-Ding war cringe.
Ups, nicht das.
Das war irgendwie komisch.
aber gut, hätte man schon drauf kommen können,
wobei selbst das nicht funktioniert hat,
also vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach nicht gecheckt.
Siehst du, ich kann auch nicht alles da.
Gut,
dann werde ich jetzt mal an die frische Luft gehen,
Chat.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Wem es gefallen hat, kann mir gerne
ein Follow da lassen.
Dann seid ihr top aktuell wieder informiert, wenn der nächste Stream online geht, weil wir machen dann weiter.
Würde mich freuen. Ich sehe immer gerne, wenn die Follows hochgehen.
Exzellent.
Und außerdem ist Followern kostenlos.
Nicht so wie Subscriben.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, wir sehen uns. Bis dann, macht's gut.
CU